foreign
[Applause]
thank you
I've not done anything yet so let's
temper that come on let's be real
all right we'll just jump into it right
that's what we
uh I'm a child of immigrants anyone hear
the child of immigrants
yeah get her hurry no I'm just kidding
raised by English people
spoke the same thing which I always had
to translate from my mother my my mother
never really adopted American English
you know she'd be like Cheerio I'd be
like she's saying goodbye
should be like oh I fancy a cup of CHA
I'd be like she's looking for tea
she'd be like tell them Tom I was like
she's saying thank you she'd be like I'm
quite knackered I'd be like she's tired
she'd be like I'm chuffed I'd be like
she's happy she'd be like oh I'm pissed
I'd be like she's drunk
she'd be like pop pop on your back Bob's
your fanny I'd be like she's saying I
actually did I don't know lay her down
something's wrong get her feet up
elevator fish she's foaming put a stick
in her mouth God damn it mommy
it was always weird to me though to
watch my parents because my parents are
taught like this and we talk like this
and I was like that's weird how did that
happen because when you think about it
it was a bunch of British people that
came to this country right to what I
understand was unoccupied land and they
came
foreign
not sure how that's still a little
controversial to us but here it is I
guess I don't know
the truth is if you really think about
it the only thing white people who came
to this country ever discovered were
trusting people but anyway gobble gobble
Happy Thanksgiving we're moving on so
[Applause]
but we talk like less they came here and
we talk like this how did that happen
well I'm glad you asked I was looking it
up
and there is a theory
that it was just a decision that they
made
I did
one day two old dusty white dudes are
hanging out
one of them's just like Winthrop mad Ben
jewelry for a moment he's like why yes
Phillips what is it is that what I just
had a thought on how we could further
separate ourselves from the British if
we desired to do so
of course
of course so we made the big move oh
is that what I was thinking what if we
were to just talk entirely differently
talk entirely differently whatever do
you mean he goes but instead of talking
like this as we're all to do he's just
thinking you know what if we were to
just no no you know
talk like this
hello
[ __ ] what have you done there you've
got the devil's tongue Shing and he's
like no that's to me it's to me he's
like ah yeah
foreign
Americans we talk differently
when did you have time to come up with
something that's brilliant he's like
well I just made time in my schedule ah
yes you mean schedule no I mean schedule
no you meet shell wow okay I wow I see
what you've done there
I don't hate it
got anything else
I have one more but it is a bit drastic
and he goes come on mate you're on a
roll out with it so what if we really
wanted to show that we are completely
independent completely different
what if we were to just
fix our teeth
it's like no you've lost me you've lost
me
you pushed it there you've lost me
you were doing so well what were you
sharpen our tools with you've not
thought this through you really
and then they just went through the rest
of the country you know they went down
south they're like I'm tired of talking
like this I was thinking maybe we could
go a little more like this direct what
do y'all think maybe a little more like
this something like that
got to the Midwest shark I'm tired of
talking like this I was thinking maybe
change her up a little bit like going
this direction kind of hit that all nice
hit that all a lot you know
got to California like tired of doing it
let's just go and let's what if we're
just a little more like what the [ __ ]
what
it's egregious you know
[Applause]
not historically accurate but it's fun
we like fun right it's fun
I don't know you know
you know they do think in times of
Shakespeare that they didn't even sound
English they think they sounded more
Bostonian
which ruins Shakespeare right away
doesn't it
all those beautiful plays and sonnets
coming out through that filter no thank
you
just back then people like come on we're
gonna go watch some Shakespeare in the
pack it's like oh I don't feel sick oh
my God I feel like I got punched
going to see it is just like alas Paul
Yorick I know this dude's so good
come on kid he's dead that's his skull
it's [ __ ]
It's Like Romeo ramireza Romeo
seriously where is this [ __ ] this
balcony is freezing my nipples are so
hard
English people are sensitive about teeth
jokes they don't like them I've learned
that one
my mother lives in England I was there
recently we were just watching game
shows hanging out out and on one of the
game shows the question came on on
average how many teeth is a British
person missing that was on a game show
yeah
I was like to all your game
say what you will about this country we
got problems but our game shows are an
Escape right you're never watching a
game show it's like on average how many
Oxycontin does a West Virginia you know
what I mean it's like
it's a distraction to distract us
the options
two four and seven for how many teeth
does a British person missing
miss you can play the at-home version
two four seven how many teeth on average
is a British person missing do you think
four she said seven you're going with
the most defensive one well my dear
you'll be interested no it was actually
seven she's right it was seven it's
seven it's obviously seven it's
obviously seven she's right come on I
wouldn't be doing the joke if it wasn't
seven seven seven seven teeth
from their heads they're not sharks
that's a lot of tea everybody okay that
is a quarter of your teeth legally
70. I was like I could not believe it I
was like 17th my uncle was over he's
like well it's not that many if you
think of that
I was like that's a lot of teeth dude he
goes no they pop out all the time oh
there goes I'm damaging another one
bites that does make a wish
and that's what I realized England isn't
a country it's just a pile of teeth that
people figured out how to grow potatoes
in
together how'd you meet
why is that funny she's like school's
crazy
why is that funny
you met in England
ah interesting right
English people love the mass culture
more than anyone I'll tell you that
they're like finally nobody knows our
secret
probably won't release that one that
will get me like I can't go see my
mother I'll just be at my mother's like
they're gone they're no they're not gone
they're not gone
how did you meet in England you were at
school in England
you studied abroad okay and you were
there studying
okay and then where
Sheffield okay and then how did you you
met in school what was the first what's
the first date in England go to the pub
yeah that's all you can do okay so what
should I get more to go to the pub we've
got two options let's do a shag at yours
great that sounds good
married
yeah do you ever go back to Sheffield
no of course not why would you you're
not English are you you are English oh
this is super awkward all of a sudden
isn't it
I just picked up on your accent you hear
that yeah yeah man no no you [ __ ]
prick
[Laughter]
and so that you don't go back
oh don't go back though
good for you made the right call
Mazel muzzle I um
I definitely found it strange being
raised by English people in America like
immigrant parents raise you with sort of
weird Traditions but the more I travel
the country talk to people the more I
realize it wasn't that my parents were
immigrants it's just parents parents
just give you a bunch of fill your head
with weird [ __ ]
and then you become a grown-up and then
you're out there like yeah we used to do
this and people like what
happened and they're like that's not
that's like like borderline abuse like
it's not a lot of it's tradition it's a
tradition
[Applause]
this one guy I was talking to him and he
was like his family didn't celebrate any
holidays except for one that they
celebrated twice a year and you like me
are probably like what holidays twice a
year well you're not gonna figure it out
because then in no way is a holiday his
family went big for daylight savings
food out there drinks people over
revelry it was an event he was a school
day of like yeah all excited it's
daylight saving spring ahead my favorite
of the two [ __ ] is
I don't even know how that works
you gotta stay up till 2 A.M you're
having a good time and then at two you
have it again I guess I'm not sure
or then it's 4 a.m and you feel like you
just did blow with your family you're
like what are we doing this is not
it's weird Everybody
I had a woman at my show she told me
about how her and her sisters would
always get their hair cut from their
Grandma all through their youth which I
thought was pretty sweet it was like a
family tradition then the grandmother
passed away and they were cleaning out
her place and they discovered that she'd
kept all that hair
their childhood hair
in a set of drawers she hid in the
closet or as I call it the hairdresser
I love that one though that's the best
Iowa that's the best
dying with that leave behind
you just have [ __ ] you're like Grandma
why she's like bye-bye bye you're like
why were you doing it's like you might
not figure it out
so what was the head maybe I was putting
in pillows you'll never know I'm gone
I'm vapor
but my favorite one was I was at a show
and I was like anyone got any weird
traditions and this guy goes I got one
birthday chicken I was like sir you talk
until you're done get him a microphone
what did you just say in a room of
people birthday chicken I was like what
is birthday chicken
and birthday chicken it turns out was in
his family they invented like a birthday
Santa the birthday chicken
sort of this mythical generous foul whom
he believed to be real
thank you
so every year on his birthday he'd get
gifts from his friends and family but
then he get one extra gift from the
birthday chicken
[Applause]
I'm all right
then he gets a little bit older
goes through the reveal that we all went
through granted his was a little
different than ours
there was an addition it was like
there's no tooth fairy there's no Santa
there's no birthday chicken he's like
I'm gonna need a minute
Santa I saw coming but birthday chicken
who is eating all the feed we put in the
living room dad oh my God
[Applause]
then he gets a little bit older he goes
to high school gets his license goes to
prom goes to college first semester
freshman year at College in his dorm
it's his roommate's birthday
and he's like his parents live far away
time to get him a birthday chicken gift
I'll do it
because what I failed to tell you is
what they failed to tell him
that they were the only people that did
it
see he knew it was [ __ ] he just
didn't know that it was only his
family's [ __ ] and that they'd
invented the [ __ ] that part never
got revealed
so he's just handing this seeming
stranger a gift with a card and this
dude just opens it and he's like love
birthday chicken
[Applause]
hahaha
foreign
thank you birthday chicken
I love my sweater
anyone have anything like that you can
think of like little granted birthday
chicken so it's a high bar obviously
yeah what do you got my parents sent me
a letter from Santa saying he wasn't
going to come visit anymore what the
[ __ ] amazing
oh my Lord Dear Bradley I hope this
letter finds you well
it won't soon
you're still a nice boy but I'm done
with you what
what did the letter say
the part
so your parents were like your parents
your first of all I'm 90 one of your
parents is a lawyer they're like legally
if we get this
we're in the clear we cannot
so then you have the illusion that sin
is real but he's just done with you
specifically
which is almost worse
Santa and I aren't doing that anymore
I've got a lead on a birthday chicken
which is actually
thank you
[Applause]
that's great
it's just a lot of kids and you're not
one of my favorites
Santa sent me a restraining order yeah
look you were being an [ __ ] to him
he said no more
oh man now I want to have kids just to
do that that's like
I'm gonna burn my rubbers to be like I'm
gonna [ __ ] with this kid be like
[Applause]
here's mine this is my family tradition
my family
when I was growing up I'd go to England
they would make us share bath water
yeah yeah there was like I was raised to
believe that was totally normal to share
bath water with relatives
I can't explain it you know a lot of
people won't take baths because like oh
gross that's your own filth right my own
filth to me as a child would have been a
dream
a dream
all right
I'd look at a bath of my own filth the
way a gruel-filled orphan had looked
through a rich person's foggy window at
a Christmas goose just like meow filth
of course someday maybe imagine me I'm
fair you know
[Applause]
it's crazy
it would be like my aunts my female
cousins they'd all share one bath then
they'd drain it they do the great
refilling and then it was man time
and let me point out this is PMS
pre-manscaping a much bushier era okay
and it would be like nine ten dudes I'd
be falling grown ass men I was a child
but I didn't think it was weird it was
the prison I was born into
but by the time it got to me it didn't
even look like bath water anymore
like Ramen at that point it was just
like oh
[Applause]
had it was the consistency of like cold
sake by the time it got to me you know
what I mean
just had to get in I just said
it's Mana Stoney this guy spacho
going there seven-year-old nubile boy
take a skunk Duncan come out of there
covered in so many hairs of various
lengths and curls that look like a
Grecian man in a nude beached just like
let's do this you know [ __ ]
my uncle come over he'd take the hair
off me give it to Grandma obviously it
was for her it was
pairing is caring hearing is caring
corrupted as youths much earlier in
England you'd see like an eight-year-old
smoking be like that's crazy I'd be like
got a problem copper you'd be like I'm
nine so you need to pump the brakes over
there first of all
sex was earlier I remember I was 12
years old and my friend was like mate
you still a virgin
what are you doing I'm 12 years old he
was like don't worry
I was like I don't want it to happen
okay I am a little boy all right this is
not Chester these are my uncle's pubes I
took a bath earlier I'm not
I'm a kid bro
[Applause]
[Music]
weed was earlier too weed yeah 12 13 was
when we started smoking weed there the
way we smoked weed there was different
than how we smoked weed here though the
way I learned to get high in England was
through what they call Rising blowbacks
now I know it sounds weird but it's just
when your buddy sucks your dick in a hot
air balloon that's all it is it says
guys it's European it's like pastries
for breakfast it's just it's their way
the lid end in their mouth and blows
through the back then you suck that in
then someone picks you up by your
sternum till your feet are off the
ground lowering your oxygen levels and
by the time your feet hit the ground
again you are real High real high so
imagine the first time in the states
when someone wanted to smoke with me you
know like you want to get baked I was
like well yeah but we're gonna need to
get a few more fellas over here Chad I
mean we'll hurt our backs foreign
[Laughter]
so one of the first times I got high
it's probably like first three times I
got hives late at night everything's
closed and we're hanging out in front of
the store and uh I'm just laughing my
ass off we're having a good little time
you know and I'm just laughing I tap the
store window nothing aggressive just
give it a little tap and my friend
Richard goes don't Gareth you Lima glove
and I go don't call me a Lima guaf
and everybody laughed
but they didn't laugh when he said it
they laughed when I said it
and I wanted to know what was going on
but I couldn't ask because I was high so
I was just like yeah you don't call me a
Lima glove what is it never mind
but I wish I'd asked because it became
like a nickname people started calling
me Lima guaf
yeah for years people you know I'd get
into town people be like hey let me go
upstairs and be like you're damn right I
am that's me I'm him
it'd be like you all right let me go up
and be like doing good little confused
still but good elima wow it's good
years went on to one night I was at a
party and my cousin introduces me to a
guy who was there that night and he goes
no no I'll remember you YOLO mcwuff I
was like yeah
so then I waited until I had a moment
and I cornered him I had to know and I
go hey why was that so funny he goes
what was what funny llama golf
I said why was it so funny when I said
don't call me a Lima glove he said well
because you hit the shop window and
Richard said don't Gareth the alarm will
go off
[Applause]
foreign
I was like well
that is funny now that I hear it back
that's pretty good honestly that's
pretty good weed too well good to catch
up hope you're well Lima guap out I'll
see ya thank you
together how'd you meet
Tinder Tinder nice how long you been
together
for [ __ ] hey that's pretty good yeah
yeah
about half the room cares she's excited
anyone got a weird way who's who's uh
who's a couple's got a weird way what do
you got back there go ahead
um
you met at clown night
yeah okay relax quit acting like I'm the
crazy one like yeah I I said that clown
Knight dumbass we met at clown night
and then you have noses on a clown knife
yeah yeah duh
what do you think makes it clown not
stupid man
can you imagine walking into a clown bar
I don't know if there's like I would
make a U-turn so fast we need to get the
[ __ ] out of here they'd be like trivia
night of course run run run start that
car
people loved you yeah well lots of
people think that and they're wrong that
happens all the time
people loved us we were loud
[Applause]
how long how long ago was that
no sir I mean I'm far but I'm not like
in another city
a trained actor
Leah's next match
foreign
you are a clown
you're still a clown
huh you got it on now
you had to get the bar through it
is it like a barbell for your nose is
this like a Saw movie
my Lord you I mean this is like feeding
an animal that won't leave you alone
this is like we're like all right go go
go get the [ __ ] out of here I put out
milk one night I'm not your daddy I
don't you know I have a cat I can't have
more
we can't have more than one clown in
this room and I'm the Clown
and sir I almost want you to keep going
so I can actually shout out one of my
shows get that clown the [ __ ] out of
here
[Applause]
toss the Clown
[Applause]
all right
and let's talk about weed we'll talk
about wheat a little bit more
I uh I'm glad they legalize wheat I
think all drugs should be legal I really
do weed is a good example right they
tried to scare us about legalizing weed
and then uh you know they did right like
leading up to the legalization of weed
they're like you cannot legalize weed
it'll be it's gonna be chaos
the streets will be filled with snack
zombies looking for things
gonna be total Madness they'll be after
our Twizzlers our our Snickers our our
Sour Patches our peanut butter-filled
pretzels our cheese balls our brittle it
Rolos it's gonna be they'll be breaking
Windows our 7-Elevens are gonna look
like 9 11. you can't do this
and then we did it and uh it was fun
right pretty much went fine the only
thing that's changed there's been a
spike in canceling plans
a lot more
plan I don't know what it is about
getting high with plans it's like I'll
have plans I'll be excited that I have
plans
then it'll be the night of the plans and
I'll get high and I'll be like what was
I thinking I gotta cancel these plans
I'm an idiot
I can't go anywhere
gotta lie to your best friend you know
like a stone Jesse Smollett you're like
there was two of them they came after me
it was pretty bad I can't
Mega hats the whole nine it was
I could probably do coffee tomorrow
before I get high that's what the doctor
says once I get out
I like that medical phase that felt
right to me medical phase right that was
awesome oh we were kids
in some states not funny
that's where you
sick
tending to be a doctor
it's fun it's like marijuana LARPing
pot cosplay right
I just kept saying medically speaking a
bunch during mine
she's like why do you need the license I
was like well medically speaking whoa
that's a pretty good start from this guy
I need it because without it medically
speaking
I can't uh
I can't get high without it medically
speaking it's it's genetic my dad had it
please help me please help fix me please
fix me
a picture in the top hat and they were
like we literally don't care I was like
all right
I walked out of there I was like have a
good day gentlemen I'm off to get ripped
[ __ ] yes
[Applause]
I looked for that license for a long
time
and then I found it like two weeks ago
you validate that that is a man and a
top hat
that is a
illegal
I should point out too I'm wearing a
tuxedo shirt and not like a shirt that
you'd put a tie around the print of a
tuxedo on a t-shirt
foreign
enjoyed watch
Ed of getting weed in my lifetime I
certainly I've been smoking weed long
enough to have really seen it evolve you
know like I think back to and I had to
get weed in high school
yeah impossible
it was easier to get rare Ivory than to
get a bag of pot
it was a weird system you had to go hang
out with a dude that was how you got it
you kind of like had to earn it by
hanging out with some weird dude some
dude who knew a dude but you'd have to
physically be in his apartment
that was how you got it you know he just
would have like a fish tank full of baby
sharks he'd be bench pressing in his
living room while he was telling you
video game high scores
you think you're gonna get it today he'd
be like won't be today no could be days
could be weeks you're like do you want
to just call me when it gets here he's
like that sounds crazy no I'll see you
tomorrow you're like okay
so when I moved to Los Angeles I still
had to go meet a dude it was a little
easier the timeline was a little more
condensed but I still had to go meet
some random dude he'd be like meet me in
this parking lot at 4 30. I'd be like
can do it'd be like 7 45 I'd be like you
close you'd be like no I'd be like okay
thank you it's been a pleasure to work
with you I'm really enjoying this
foreign
it's just so easy to get it right like
back then you'd go meet that dude you
didn't know what kind of weed you were
getting there were no types of weed I
didn't know what kind of weed this guy
was giving me there was one kind of weed
the weed he gave you that was it
that crazy to think of that now
that should be like imagine walking into
a bar and being like one alcohol please
like that's what we were doing
[Applause]
and now I really do feel like we've
almost over corrected like it's easier
to get weed now than it is to get
quarters for laundry
foreign
[Applause]
it's become so serious now like you walk
into the weed store they're like all
right and your blood type and star sign
you're like no no I just please weed
sometimes you're in line behind the
people who take it real seriously they
get that magnifying broadhouse that has
a light switch on it you know
just be like oh man that's great look at
those purple hairs that's awesome what
county is this from loving the crystals
foreign
look at those crystals they're like sir
that's the tip jar I'm like yeah but
it's still very shiny that's awesome
there's a lot of Corners in there which
is good for you all
could I actually grab some of those I'm
doing laundry later I'm having trouble
locating
some quarters for myself personally as
of late
doesn't matter where you stand on weed
everyone is taking gummies
smokers non-smokers everybody's rocking
gummies people love the gummies
Evangelical preachers will be like
marijuana is a narcotic you may not but
you can have a gummy you could take a
gummy I'd take a gummy before I walk the
dog makes it more interesting it's in
Leviticus you can
you may
you know it's really rocking the gummies
senior citizens
we got him
candy that was how we we got him he's
sitting right there so obvious candy
senior citizens love gummies
I was at a show talking about gummies 85
year old woman in my show goes I used to
take gummies I was like used to
she goes I'd always take a half I was
like okay she goes then one day I took a
hole I was like uh oh she goes uh oh
it's right
called 9-1-1 I was like what
what did you tell them
she goes I told them I took a gummy they
knew what to do they knew what to do
it's that common that they know what to
do
there's probably like a tented triage
attached to most Hospitals now senior
citizens sprawled out on gurneys having
just og'd over gummy some exhausted
doctor running around they're like give
me 15 inch Shores all the soft fudge you
could find it for God's sake put Mash on
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
I'm on a break from wait I took a break
from weight I've just smoked enough weed
in my lifetime that I'm like good for a
while you know
I Love Weed I love wheat I'm the guy who
before the show tonight you'd all be
waiting to come inside but you'd have to
wait for me because I'd be outside
hitting the bowl like a crack pipe
and you just be like how high do you
need to be for this and I'd be like I'm
not getting high for now I'm getting
high for two hours from now okay like
how a camel drinks a bunch of water
before it goes into the desert I'm
filling my weed humps
there are some things I like about not
smoking weed for sure like I like
walking into a room and knowing why
that's addictive
that is addictive I'll be honest they
were right about that one
or like remembering where I parked my
car in a parking garage that's good I
like that one too every movie I ever saw
I'd always walk out and be like all
right
this part
walk around for five minutes eventually
flag down the security guard get in
their cart you know
just be like make and models sir I'm not
sure I might not have even driven here
tonight this might be a Fool's errand
[Applause]
smoke no all right thank you
the only time I would take breaks other
than this last one would be when I would
go see my mother in England she wouldn't
score me weed she was real Square you
know
[Laughter]
so last time I went there I took CBD
with me you know a lot of people like
CBD doesn't work you don't feel anything
that's not true you take enough CBD you
feel like you really wish you had weed
you were like that'd be great way to be
great
my mother
she saw that I I had CBD she goes gut
anymore like it was a quaalude at Studio
54. I was like lady
can literally buy this at the grocery
store
[Applause]
so I gave her one
right I'm not kidding you could give
this CBD to a gerbil there'd be no
noticeable difference
my mother tripped tripped
she was fried like an egg she was swung
out on her couch
just like oh my God I go are you okay
she goes the colors are so vivid I was
like this is a white room
but she couldn't hear me I just looked
in her eyes and all she was hearing was
[Applause]
same trip though right right before I'm
flying back my cousin gives me a weed
edible that he made for me
now that is a dicey situation
I want to know the potency always right
my rule of Edibles is you can always
take more never less right choo choo
wait like a delayed Amtrak that's how I
handle it
but this is for a flight international
travel so you got to make a decision
before you go into Customs how much you
want to eat
because you can't have it on you in your
pocket but you can't have it in you
inside God's Pocket
so I'm like [ __ ] it let's go big
oopsie poopsie yeah it was a it was a
bad call No Doubt bad call I made the
wrong call I got the highest I've ever
been
the highest I've ever I was so high that
I didn't know I was high like I crossed
through the Event Horizon I was that
high
and I know a lot of people who even
smoke weed are like what does that mean
I wouldn't know what it means unless it
happened to me but I got so high that I
needed to figure out that I was high
and there were a few red flags on the
way to the moment of Revelation
the first one was I was sitting on the
plane and I couldn't find my phone
anywhere I was checking every I tore my
bag apart I was looking under my seat
you know and then eventually found it in
my pocket
and I was just like it was like I did a
magic trick on myself I was like how did
I do that that was my phone yeah
the second red flag was I was sitting
there and I became obsessed with the
idea of taking off my boxer shorts and
only wearing my pants foreign
it was either think about it the whole
flight or do it so I had to go do it
so I got up went to the plane bathroom
went inside there joined a different
mile high club okay now what went on in
there can only be described as a
slapstick silent film comedy
there should have been a piano player
outside like
this I had like egads popping up and
stuff like that
around in there
and they're soft knocking [ __ ] down I
was like oh my God this isn't going too
well you know
but eventually got him off right had the
boxers didn't really know what to do
with them so I just sort of jammed them
in my pant pocket
I got a clown hanky you know
hanky to some of us all right sir get
that clown the [ __ ] out of here
[Applause]
I'm kidding he may stay
[Applause]
he's in a party of 30. they all get in
his car all right come on guys let's go
let's go let's go let's go let's go
let's go let's go let's go let's go
let's go let's go let's go let's go
let's go
if anyone asked me what it was just
gonna go got a bit of a runny nose
but that wasn't it
where I realized was I was sitting there
okay and I'm watching a movie and as I'm
watching a movie I'm like the worst part
about the mask is how much it fogs up
your glasses then I'm like you're not
wearing glasses
you don't wear glasses
then I started thinking back I was like
my phone the clown hanky oh my God I'm
high
I was so high that I've been on a lot of
planes but I was so high on this flight
that I was looking out the window like
we're so high right now we'd already
landed by the way I was like oh my God
the people look like people from up here
man
the flight attendant came over she said
something to me I couldn't understand
her though all I heard was
[Music]
I uh I was trying to get weed in Mexico
once not easy right I was searching all
over eventually I bought it off a cab
driver
I should have known it was not good weed
when I got it in a garbage bag I was
like this is probably not gonna be great
weed
it was it was terrible right but I was
like there were like seeds and stems in
it I was like oh yeah those things right
but so I rolled a bunch of joints I was
smoking them I was smoking them in my
hotel room down at the beach I was
walking down the street smoking joints
maybe getting a little too comfortable
right and at one point I'm walking by
and I see this like little discotheque
and I'm like oh maybe I'll go in there
you know it's like look at those lights
that's pretty cool you know and then I'm
like oh wait it's like a barber shop why
is a barber shop have like disco lights
and I'm like oh wait those aren't even
disco lights those are like sirens I'm
like oh wait those aren't even coming
from inside they're actually a
reflection I'm like oh wait Reflections
means it behind you and I was like oh
wait those are cops I was like oh wait I
have weed and I just threw it like four
feet from me
and then the cops came over you know
they found it they were pretty good
detectives obviously they
thorough and um
so they coughed me put me in the back of
the cop car right driving me away now
the one guy his job is to just drive but
the other guy his job is to just
disparage the quality of the weed to my
face
so he's just holding the bag up and he's
like man this is some bad weed I was
like yeah it has not been good to me I
agree it's not great
it's like this is I can't believe you're
going to jail for this oregano I was
like yeah no it's not good I'm not proud
of it it really is not worth it in any
way you know
he was just like what did you pay for
these lawn clippings I was like sir I
feel like whatever I say to you you're
going to overreact because that seems to
be your attitude but forty dollars he
goes forty dollars I was like I knew
that that was what you do
then at one point they pulled over and
he goes look we don't want to take you
to jail and I was like well sir we
finally have some common ground because
you're not gonna believe this I don't
want to go to jail so look at us
he goes if you go to that ATM and get
out 200 we'll let you go I was like
that's can do so I went I got 200 out of
the ATM gave gave it to him right they
let me go as I was walking away he goes
hey you forgot something and he threw
the weed at me
this is a better judicial system
I just got arrested interrogated
processed had my hearing posted bail got
released and my [ __ ] back in 45 minutes
we should be doing that honestly
way better
are you waving to me
oh that's a thumbs up oh you gotta
understand people were clapping and
you're like giving me the queen wave
I was like what
that's a better that's better than
clapping I want that more people to do
that yeah that's good
are you here with someone I can't really
see
three other people okay how do you all
know each other
and this is the first time you're seeing
each other 10 years at this show how did
this happen
okay
[Applause]
anyone taking some gummies Over Yonder
she might just be an apparition my
friend from 10 years ago is here the
word is part as she's passed away
so did you arrange to see each other
she arranged to see you
how did you see the one you haven't seen
in 10 years did you decide you were
going to come to this together
okay
[Applause]
so you don't know who I am you were like
we'll do this
right okay all right all right that's
great
what do you think so far are you having
a good time yeah okay yeah I saw you
having a good time because you waved at
me so I know you're
that's how I could tell you're like
hello oh
[Applause]
all right now we're going to talk about
the rest this is just uh this is a bit
of a hodgepodge potpourri
of other stuff so uh I'm a single man I
uh lived with a female friend of mine
for the past couple years it was fine
obviously it's been a while since I
lived with a woman there are certain
things I forgot like I always consider
women to be cleaner than men and I think
for the most part that is true right
tidier at least but I will say the
bathroom is where that playing field
gets real leveled
that's where women come to life right
like there's a lot of stuff I was just
like what is going on like they're
always fingerprints on the mirror which
I was like as a man I've never touched
the mirror
I don't even know how that happened
she's just in there like someday
[Applause]
women also get very ambitious with that
bathroom trash can
yeah you do you believe in that thing
questions
to me it's a baby trash
have high expectations for this
receptacle
Q-tips fly
empty it once a year
kind of a big deal when you empty it
right it's like a ceremony you're like
come on we're empty and baby get your
sister we're emptying baby trash out
back
around you know you're like baby trash
had a good year find your baby trash hat
huh
good harvest I think right we can use
the same CVS bag for another year I
think right
it's got that little hole in it
it's not that women feel it it's that
you pack it in like sand
what is the long-term strategy here
just like live to fight another day
Brenda uh smush
you work for make
[Applause]
I just walked in there one day it's lid
wouldn't even close I was like what are
you doing to Baby to your killing baby
trash look like a big curb stomped I was
like look at him look at him
yeah
I eventually had to empty it was not
easy to do it's concreted in there
had to put like a weightlifting Bell to
have a buddy come over to spot me I'll
shake it shake it shake it right it's
like giving a nerd a swirly I was like
drop drop drop
when it finally dropped it was like a
magician's pocket I couldn't believe all
the stuff that was in there nail polish
people magazines I was like is that a
bottle of red wine what the [ __ ] are you
doing in here this is a bathroom this is
a bathroom
foreign
yeah seems like a nightmare but it is a
lot of hair
you ever get a haircut on your hand you
can't get off
yeah a haircut in your hand you can't
get off right you just work on it for 10
minutes like get over there you know
finally you do it then you're rubbing
your fingers together 30 seconds later
you're like that bastard still there
won't leave
women have come up with an amazing
technique for when that happens to them
in the shower to get rid of that hair
yes you already know do you already know
women ain't got time for that they're in
the shower they got stuff to shave
women ain't got time for that so they'll
just take those finger hairs and just
strewn them along the shower tile
Hair by hair strand by strand one by one
lock by lock
started decking the halls in there it's
got a festive nature to it
over the months it takes on the
appearance of jungle vines in some parts
one day I just looked over I was like
what the [ __ ] is going on over here what
some of the side hairs almost look like
like bad cursive it's like a dead
language
looks like cave paintings from a far
gone culture I'm just like [ __ ] look at
this [ __ ] I need the Rosetta Stone she's
trying to tell me something she's
communicating through hair it's like
hieroglyphics
foreign
I eventually had to get rid of it came
up with a technique I call the dick
sprinkler
be in the shower one day and be like all
right [ __ ] it and I just fill my palm
with water and be like got it got it got
it got it you know
those hairs are dropped down right then
eventually the shower drain clogs that
was the next chapter
suddenly the water is at calf level
whenever you're taking a shower you're
not taking a shower anymore you're
taking what can only be described as a
shaft you know
stomping around in there furiously like
the grape stomping lady you're like God
damn it this isn't a life I'm gonna get
trench foot this is [ __ ]
I had to unclog it you know she came in
she's like what do you think it was I
was like I don't know maybe it's just
treasure troll you that lives down there
think it might be that it just blinked
huh
said Mama right
I throw it in the baby trash but there's
no [ __ ] room
let's talk about America uh land that I
love land that I love land that I'm a
little concerned about I'm not gonna lie
let me start
by saying this
I have stopped flying I don't fly to
shows anymore not because of the edible
boxer short thing it's
irrelevant other reasons I stopped
flying because they cancel 1800 flights
a day I just got sick of the gate
swapping of the missing bags not being
able to locate Pilots sitting on the
tarmac for five hours just got sick of
it and the thing that really drove me
crazy is the whole time they're screwing
you they are thanking you for your
patience
I want to thank you for your patience
while you don't get to your destination
we want to thank you for your patience
while you don't get your bag it's like
that's not how patience worked there's
nothing more infuriating than being
thanked for patients that you're not
giving so I stopped I stopped I stopped
as soon as I realized that the FAA
wasn't an acronym it was just short for
[ __ ] you
so I quit so now I drive to all my shows
I drive to all my shows and I am seeing
a lot of the country a lot of it and let
me tell you it ain't good
not good things are not good everything
is broken
it's all broken elevators don't work
escalators are weird stairs both
bathrooms are out of order hand
sanitizer dispensers are empty that one
I particularly hate going up for a score
to hand sanitizer because you feel like
your hands dirty go up and you're like
I'll take some of that and then you're
just touching it nothing's coming out
you're like wait so now my hand is
touching all the hands of people who
thought they were dirty enough to
Warrant hand sanitizer and now their
germs and my germs are just having a
germ orgy no
foreign
and they're just not gonna fix [ __ ] the
government is just done fixing stuff
that's their plan both parties they're
done fixing [ __ ] right the only thing
our political parties are fixing are
prices and primaries that's it
and I don't actually
even call
[Applause]
the people doing nothing who belong in
the ground so I call them political
funerals
and I am not a member of either of our
political funerals and it's very freeing
because I'm able to agree with
everyone's gripes right people be like
Republicans or religious cults sliding
into fascism I'm like yes yep yes
they'll be like Democrats use their
wokeness to get away with their out in
the open corruption I'm like right
exactly yep yes
and I know people are like well no my
team's good
of course they do they care about you
they love you just like the birthday
chicken loves you
he loves you his love is real his love
is great
and we enable it in this country we let
him get away with it because we still
have a lot of people walking around this
country saying that this is the best
country on Earth hear that all the time
it's the best country on Earth America
is not even the best country in America
anymore okay
it isn't most people are saying that
America is the best country on Earth
just haven't left it
it's not fair that would be like an
Amish man being like the best sex of my
life was with my wife right here
and my favorite position threw a hole in
the sheet for procreation it's like you
need something to compare it to
can't just do that
and I'll tell you people get pissed off
when you talk like this they do they
don't like it I've done this material at
shows I've had people shout if you don't
like it get the [ __ ] out it was in Napa
known for its wines
but why is it like that why can't I
complain
are we that sensitive why can't I give
this country tough love it doesn't work
like that with people if you have people
in your life that you care about and
they're [ __ ] up you give them tough
love you talk to them you make it hard
for them you tell them the hard truths
they need to hear to get better because
you love them but in this country you
can't do that like let's say I had a
buddy named Dan and every time we go out
Dan jumps behind the bar steals a bottle
of vodka pounds it whips his dick out
mushes it into the bar olives and calls
it a mantini extra dirty
I'd probably pull him aside
I'd say something to him I'd be like hey
Dan that's not cool you can't do that
I mean did I laugh at the mantini part
sure I did
I'm only human
I want to stand in front of him and be
like if you don't like it get the [ __ ]
out d-a-n -d-a-n
[Music]
[Applause]
I'm just saying if we're gonna live in a
collapsing Empire let's at least just be
honest about it
because right now America is walking
around like it's Blue Suede Shoes Elvis
looks good is new one of a kind shakes
its hips and everybody feels real nice
but in reality we are late stage Vegas
sitting in a stained jumpsuit passed out
on a toilet full of barbiturates
clinging to a half-eaten ham and peanut
butter sandwich Elvis
with a few Rich dicks standing around us
looking thinking how can we get one more
hit out of this half dead shell foreign
Erica is a good comparison because they
both got where they did by stealing from
black people so
and I know some people are like Jesus
would enough with this guy right look
I'm just up here working on material and
while I do I thank you for your patience
thank you
the upside is we live in a time when
we're probably going to get to watch a
billionaire explode in space so
that's pretty exciting right
are you waving for that one miss no wave
on that one okay yeah thumbs up I like
to see it she's like yeah no [ __ ] them
[ __ ] them yeah we might get to see a
billionaire explode in space that's
exciting screw fireworks that's what I
want
I watch every launch live
I watch every launch live I want to see
it live I don't want to catch the
highlights later I want it live I'm
making food I have drinks out I have
people over it's an event it's like
daylight savings I'm really I go big
nothing would make me happier than watch
one of those things just pop
[Laughter]
I want Bezos
I'm being greedy
[Applause]
greedy
space like I was like oh give me give me
give me
I would just love to see that thing
popping that hat feather down to earth
right
it's watching it it's like
be like whoa got here so fast same day
like Prime
I appreciate y'all showing up for this
llama Guapo thank you very much
appreciate it thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you babe
[Music]
foreign
foreign